[Music]
i want to share with you today a story
about israelis and palestinians
but it's not about war
and it's not about conflict
it's a story of the technology bridge
that we're building between the two
people
so the story starts on an airplane in
2017.
i opened my eyes just as the pilot
announced our descent onto israel
i could see the te vive skyline shining
brightly in the distance and can make
out the logos of facebook google wix and
waze plastered on the facades of the
high rises
home but this time i was going as part
of a delegation from washington there to
observe different policy trends and
shifting dynamics
looking at my home through a fresh set
of eyes i was amazed by the technology
boom that my country was experiencing
with over 7 000 startups 400
multinationals and 84 unicorns
israel was one of the most advanced
technological ecosystems on the planet
and had earned the nickname of startup
nation
but it wasn't all great
startup nation was in danger one of our
speakers informed us
she presented us with this report put
together by the israeli innovation
authority that stated that at any given
moment there were over fifteen thousand
job openings and technical
startups and tech companies
and that those companies are just
struggling to fill them
this was huge technology is by far
israel's greatest economic driver
and now it was at a danger of hitting a
glass ceiling because of a shortage in
engineers
the next day i went on my first visit to
a palestinian city
as an israeli citizen i'm not allowed to
go into palestinian cities without a
special permit
and i could feel the tension building in
my body as we made it into the
unfamiliar territory
had a lot of
preconceptions about what the city might
look like
or how hostile it may feel
those were all shattered as soon as we
made it into the beautiful city of
rawabi the heart of the palestinian tech
sector that happens to be
just a little over an hour's drive from
the home that i grew up in
in rwabi we were greeted by a panel of
engineers that told us that every year 3
000 palestinian software engineers
graduated into the labor market but that
over 90 percent of them were unable to
find jobs in the still nascent
palestinian tech sector
i looked at my colleagues
were they hearing this
a shortage of 15 000 engineers in
israeli companies and not an hour away
thousands of palestinians engineers
looking for jobs
could these pieces be connected
i certainly thought that they could in
fact i was so convinced that i started
techbridge an organization that
connected israeli and palestinian tech
we worked with israeli tech companies
with job openings and we encouraged them
to fill those openings with palestinian
talent
some were wary they were just convinced
that employing palestinian engineers is
not a good idea
but most
were simply excited they had no idea
that there were palestinian software
engineers looking for jobs
and were excited by the opportunity to
hire local talents
we also worked with palestinian software
engineers straight out of college
creating a training program for them to
hone in on those hard skills and gain
that a little bit of experience for
landing that first job out of college
now tech bridge is just one of many
incredible organizations working to
enhance cross-border collaborations
between the israeli and palestinian tech
ecosystems
and today
we have nearly 1 000 palestinian
software engineers working for israeli
startups and israeli branches of
multinationals
so melanox for example an israeli
company that was recently sold for seven
billion dollars
employs over 150 palestinian software
engineers 30 of them working remotely
out of
gaza freitas an israeli startup in the
freight industry
actually established an r d center in
ramada a palestinian city and we were
already seeing ex-freitas employees
going and starting their own ventures
fueling the palestinian tech ecosystems
and creating new jobs
and hopefully this is just the beginning
now there's so much more that i would
love to tell you about the challenges
and opportunities in this space
the next few minutes
i want to share with you what excites me
most about it
so first
i'm excited about palestinian software
engineers working with israeli tech
companies
because it's simply a obvious market
solution to a market problem
it has incredible positive externalities
but at its core
it's business driven which ensures its
organic
growth you have a demand for israeli you
have a demand for engineers on the
israeli side and you have a supply of
engineers looking for jobs on the
palestinian side
as we've all learned in introductory
microeconomics
barring structural barriers market
forces will lead these two into
equilibrium
in other words it just makes business
sense to match palestinian software
engineers looking for jobs with israeli
tech companies
the second reason that i'm excited about
this space
is because it's a rare instance where
tangible action
does not benefit one side at the expense
of the other side
but rather creates a win-win situation
benefiting both israelis and
palestinians and increasing economic
prosperity in the region as a whole
so instead of dividing the pie like in
so many other instances related to
israeli palestinian palestinian
relations
we're actually enlarging the pie
and finally the third reason that i'm
excited about this space
is that it's simply an opportunity for
us to get to know each other
as israelis
many of us have never met a palestinian
and when we hear the word palestinian
it's often connected with violence
and many palestinians have only seen
israeli soldiers with their talk to view
as their enemies
and suddenly you have israelis and
palestinians working shoulder to the
shoulder this is an incredible
opportunity for us to get to know each
other to replace alienation with
familiarity
and to replace a faceless enemy
with a friendly face
so why am i telling you guys all of this
most of you are neither israeli nor
palestinian
many of you are in tech and i hope you
find these market opportunities as
exciting as i do
but even if you don't
i'm going to take a bet here and say
that
all of you have read about palestinians
and israelis in the news or
had a conversation about the
israeli-palestinian conflict in the past
year and thought to yourself
this is hopeless
so i wanted to share this story with you
today to give you a fresh perspective a
story of hope rather than one of despair
so even if you have no connection to the
region whatsoever this is my ask of you
the next time you read about
palestinians and israelis in the news
remember that there's also good news
coming out of the region
flip to the business section of the
newspaper and look for the next
israeli-palestinian founded unicorn
and help
bring a breath of fresh air into the
global conversation of a decade-old
conflict
thank you
[Music]